accumulated all of this debt by the time
you die does that debt get deferred on
your kids or your family members most
people especially High net worth
individuals are going to have some sort
of very big life insurance policy when I
die there's a big nut that's going to go
to Layla or in the reverse and that
would more than cover any kind of yeah
next thing is that it depends on how the
debt is being taken you were doing an
asset-backed loan as long as you're
continuing to make the minimum interest
payments if the company that you're
taking it against can make the cash flow
from that company and it's growing at a
faster Pace indefinitely basically yeah
a private company setting so like in a
company that's not publicly traded or
the asset would not be considered like
liquid it would have to go through a
more formal process of getting getting
or putting debt on the company big
picture if it's a publicly traded Equity
or it's a real estate asset something
that's a very well understood asset
there are plenty of lenders who will
lend off that because they can value the
risk of the asset